enfin une audi en des trophées blast et
moi tous les ans je demande notamment en
algérie et ce que j'ai à faire là bas je
parle même pas lara allet concours
comment tu vas faire je t'ai dit je pars
une semaine si rien c'est papa l'on
dirait paris où est enterré
la pdg de chitwan âgées via je te
présente composantes de la folie le
bienvenu ici comment ça va l'algérie
c'est un pays riche
un jury si un pays riche mais on n'a pas
d'argent un peu d'intimité
c'est possible ça je suis comme en 2008
on aura ce n'existe pas
on est capable jack walsh a des lettres
à la france c'est mon père qui devait
partir à la france alors pas tu es né là
bas
et moi je sois né ici c'est comme ça
commencer il est parti en france
je suis français je veux juste rentrer
chez moi c'est que vous êtes française
pas marqué sur votre pour moi et je n'ai
pas une semaine est débloqué
horaires tous se marier avec elle et 6
depuis je suis tout petit quand on me
demande d'où juin 10 juin d'algérie
content j avais jamais mis les pieds
droit de faire ça
dégagement et sept femmes immigrées
quand vous qui va nous expliquer comment
gérer notre pays
à
on savait rien du pays de mes parents où
il était né comment il avait grandi
on est jamais trop curieux quand il
s'agit de sa propre histoire